Okay, so um we are starting an overview
of Greek history.
Remember the story so far?
Um we talked about the Bronze Age
um and where Mycenaean Greece
um was trading and fighting with the
rest of the world.
And then the Bronze Age collapse
happened and Mycenaean Greece came to an
end.
And because of its destruction, this
allowed for massive innovation
throughout Greece. So, we saw the
introduction of the polis, the
city-state.
Okay?
Um we saw the beginning of the use of
the alphabet. And so, literacy rates
increased radically
uh throughout uh Greece.
And we saw Homer,
uh who gave us the Iliad and the
Odyssey.
Um so, today I'm just going to go over
um the overview
of uh Greek history. Uh mainly focusing
on the polis, okay?
Um so, one thing to understand about the
polis is that geography
is destiny.
Okay?
Geography
is destiny. And this basically means
that the your geography will determine
the culture,
the economy, and the political structure
of your society. And we see that um with
the Greek polis. Uh the Greek geography
is very diverse. There are mountains,
there are rivers, there are plains, and
there are coastlines, okay?
And this And depending on where you are
geographically in Greece, you will have
a different type of polis. And so, the
two classic examples are Sparta and
Athens.
Uh Sparta and Athens are the two most
dominant poleis in about the year 500
BC, okay?
So, let's first talk about Sparta.
So, Sparta is located
on the Peloponnese.
Uh this is Sparta.
And
the land
around Sparta is basically plains, which
makes it makes it ideal for agriculture.
Okay? So, for most of its history, Spar-
Sparta was an agricultural
uh nation.
And because
it
uh is ideal for agriculture, it needs
people to work the land.
And through its
um conquest,
Sparta developed a slave system. Okay?
And these people are called helots. And
helots are just slaves
um in Sparta that work the land. They're
farmers. And these are people who have
been conquered by Sparta.
And because there are so many helots,
okay? The ratio is about 10 to 1. So,
for every one helot, uh sorry, for every
one Spartan, there's 10 helots.
Sparta had to become a military society
in order to control the helots.
So, it created um an education education
system in order to train its citizens to
be soldiers.
So, so the system worked like this.
Um about age seven about age seven, you
left your family and you were put into a
boarding school where you watched over
by kids who were older than you, okay?
Maybe 11 or 12.
And obviously, if you put young kids
with older kids, the older kids will
beat the crap out of these young kids
who are about seven or seven or eight.
And this instills the idea of emotional
discipline
into the children.
Now, when these children became
teenagers, they were paired with a
mentor who was maybe 25 to about 30,
okay? An older adult. And they became
lovers.
Um the Spartans did not consider this
homosexuality. We would consider it
homosexuality, but they themselves did
not consider this homosexuality, okay?
They just considered this as a way to
build emotional cohesion,
uh love among its soldiers.
And about age 18 or 19, the students
would graduate
and they would go on to marry and have
their own families.
But the Spartan soldiers were all
required to eat together, okay? So, the
soldiers, even though they had families,
they were still required to train
together and to eat together.
Spartan Sparta had no private property.
Everything, including the helots,
belonged to everyone, okay? So, it's
basically communism or proto-communism.
They had no money system. They had no
wealth. Everything belonged to uh
everyone.
And it was a brutal state, okay? The
Spartans were notorious for being brutal
people. So, an example is
uh the helots. So, they had a they had a
campaign of terror to maintain control
over the helots. So, um young soldiers
were often be required to
uh patrol at night.
Okay? They would they would maybe lie in
the fields because now and then some
helots would break curfew. They would at
midnight try to sneak out and have some
fun. And And if you as a Spartan young
man saw a helot
be
uh out at night, well, they would kill
you. They would take out a knife and
stab you in the neck, okay? And this was
meant to instill terror in the helots
to prevent them from rebelling, okay?
But the But the problem is because there
were so many helots
and the Spartans were so brutal,
rebellions and revolutions would break
out often.
Okay? So, this created a society
um which focused on maintaining control
in
the Peloponnese. So, the Spartans were
not at all interested
in foreign policy, okay? They had
absolutely no interest in the in the
world outside Sparta.
The Spartans
as as a culture was very conservative,
okay?
They liked the way that fit They liked
the way
They wanted things to stay the way
uh
they they are, okay?
Um so, it was a very conformist culture.
Now and then you had some kings
um or individuals who tried to change
society and the Spartans would kill
those people, okay? You were not allowed
to question
uh authority. You were not allowed to
promote change in Sparta.
The Spartans were also isolationists,
okay?
Their entire policy was, "If you leave
us alone, we'll leave you alone."
Okay?
And so, that was the
um society of Sparta. And if you think
about it, in many ways, it's very much
like China
throughout its history, okay?
So, the analogy is China, which China
has always been throughout its his- its
history very conservative and very
isolationist. China is just not
interested in the outside world. Why?
Because it's focused on maintaining
control over
um its peasantry, okay? There's too much
internal chaos. China just is not
interested in the outside world. So,
China for its history has both both both
been conservative, does not like change,
okay? And very isolationist. Is not
concerned about the outside world.
Does that make sense, guys?
Any questions so far?
About Sparta before I move on to Athens.
Okay. So, Athens was a completely
opposite society to Sparta. And the
reason why, again, is geography. This is
Sparta.
Sorry, this is Athens.
And Athens is in Attica
um
and it's by the coast.
And Athens, the countryside is very
hilly. So, it's bad for growing crops.
But Athens has two major advantages. The
first major advantage is it has a very
good harbor.
Okay? And also, it's
um
it's hilly, but the hilly terrain is
actually good for growing olive trees.
Okay? Olives.
Um it's it's also very good at pottery.
So, because of this, Athens for most of
its history focused on trade, right? It
was a trading nation.
And because they are traders and
merchants,
uh they have a very different culture to
the uh
Spartans, okay? So, the first thing is
they're very expansionist, okay? They're
aggressive.
And the idea here is the Athens will go
and seek out new markets. They also
uh plant new colonies throughout the
uh Aegean. This is To the west is the
Aegean Sea. To the south is the
Mediterranean, okay? And they will plant
colonies
um throughout this area.
Um and they have to encourage their
citizens to go out and explore the world
in order to find new markets in order to
get to bring goods and ideas back to
um Athens.
Okay?
Um because
Athens was expansionist,
its cultural system, its cultural
beliefs, was very different from the
Spartans, okay? So, whereas the Spartans
were very conservative, the
uh Athenians had a policy, had a belief
in the idea of eudaimonia.
Eudaimonia.
So, eudaimonia
is a Greek word, and it means human
flourishing.
Flourishing.
And the idea here is
to be the best that you can be. All
right? So, the example of eudaimonia,
the most famous example of eudaimonia is
this.
In Homer's Iliad,
the main character is Achilles. And
Achilles is the best warrior
uh of the Greeks against Troy.
And Achilles says this in the book. He
says, "Before I come to Troy, I saw a
prophet. I saw a fortune teller, and he
told me my fortune.
He said I could choose to not come to
Troy
and live to be a live a very long,
healthy life,
but I'd be a nobody.
If I came to Troy, I would die young,
but I would die as a hero. I'd be
remembered
by everyone.
Everyone would sing of my glory and my
triumph."
So, that was my choice. I could live for
a very long time and just be a nobody,
or I could be a hero and die young. And
he said, "Well, for me, that's not a
choice."
Okay?
For me, to be alive means to achieve
eudaimonia. I have to be the best that I
can be, and therefore, my only option is
to come to Troy and die a hero.
Okay? And that's the mentality in
Athens. It is much better to die young
as a hero than to live a long time as a
nobody.
Whereas the Spartans were the complete
opposite, okay? It's just better to be a
nobody
uh and get along with everyone
than it is to die as a hero. Okay? So,
very So, very opposite societies.
Um, but and what this did, this idea of
eudaimonia, it made Athens into a very
competitive
society, okay? Because if everyone's
trying to achieve eudaimonia,
then you're going to have a lot of
competition, okay?
Because they could They're going to be
one hero. Everyone cannot be a hero.
There going to be one hero. So, again,
the example is um
Homer's Iliad, and when Achilles got
into a fight with Agamemnon,
okay?
Achilles basically says, "I don't like
you. You're a dog. I'm not going to
fight for you." And Agamemnon says, "I
don't need you." What Achilles did was
he went to his mother, who was a
goddess, and Achilles said to Thetis, uh
his his mother,
"Could you please get the gods to help
the Trojans
so
that Agamemnon would have to come back
for my help again
against the Trojans, okay?" He was
basically committing treason.
And in the Greek world, you're allowed
to do that because the most important
thing is eudaimonia, to achieve
eudaimonia. Okay? Does that make sense?
It's a very weird world, but in Athens,
it's extremely competitive, where
everyone's trying to backstab each other
in order to become the hero.
And because of this,
because there's so so much competition,
Athens created a new system called
ostra- ostracize.
Okay? So, the idea here is because the
Athenians were so at each other's
throat,
if someone was breaking the rules, or if
someone was being too competitive in the
pursuit of eudaimonia, the Athenian
people could choose to ostracize this
person. And what this meant was you'd be
banished.
Okay? Banished or exiled
from Athens for 10 years.
And this was considered even worse than
death, okay? This punishment was worse
than death. The reason why is in the
polis system,
the only people that matter were
citizens, okay?
And the Greek world was very
chauvinistic or closed, which meant that
you could not
be You You could not earn the right to
be a citizen. You had to be born to
become a citizen. You understand? You
had to be born into into
cit- citizenship. You could not become a
citizen through your own hard work and
for your merit, okay? Does that make
sense?
So, in other words, if you were banished
from your polis, you became a nobody.
You were basically dead to everyone.
Because only citizens had rights in the
Greek world. If you were a slave or you
were a foreigner, you had absolutely no
right. You could not own land. You could
not even speak in public, okay? Does
that make sense?
All right.
Um
So,
Athens was a democracy
where
everyone had the right to speak and to
vote, okay? But really, when we talk
about democracy in this world, what what
what I'm saying is that everyone could
become president or everyone could
become a leader.
Really, political power could only be
held by people of
um
nobility, okay? So, democracy Democracy
usually was a battle between different
factions of the nobility, usually
between the upper nobility
and the lower nobility.
Okay?
And this is a lesson that's true
throughout history, okay? So, remember,
usually we think history, societies,
um the conflict is between the haves and
the have-nots, right? The poor and the
rich. All right? Haves
versus have-nots.
What I would teach you in this class One
important thing I will teach you in this
class is this is not true, okay?
If you look at history, the conflicts
in society are usually between the have
a lot and have somewhat more. Does that
make sense, okay?
It's usually between the have a lot
versus the have some,
but I want more. Okay?
And throughout history, we call these
people different names. So,
um
in this society, these are basically the
lower nobility, okay? These are peop-
the nobility who have money, but they
want more, okay?
And
um
in the French Revolution, we'll call
them the petite bourgeoisie. And today,
we call them the middle class, okay?
Does that make sense?
The poor people do not rebel. They might
riot, but they do not revolt. It's
usually the middle class or the lower
nobility
or the pet- petite bourgeoisie that
revolt.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. So, Athens is a democracy,
and it's usually conflict between the
upper nobility and the low- lower
nobility. Um, Sparta is an oligarchy,
okay?
Which is basically means rule by the
few, and they hate democracy. So, so
these systems, these cultures, Sparta
and Athens, are diametrically opposed to
each other. They hate each other.
Uh they're always in conflict with each
other. Okay? Does that make sense?
Any questions so far about Sparta and
Athens?
Are you guys clear about this?
These two different cultures. All right.
So, this is about the year 500 BCE.
Um
Around this time, the Greeks are
colonizing
uh
the Mediterranean and the Aegean, okay?
And this territory belongs to Persia.
The Persian Empire is considered one of
the greatest empires ever in human
history. We will do the Persian Empire
uh later this semester, okay? But I want
to focus on the Greeks for now.
All you need to know is the Persian
Empire spread throughout most of the
world, including Egypt, uh Mesopotamia,
um and what we call Iran today, okay? It
was a huge, huge empire that was
extremely enlightened for its age, okay?
It was really considered
uh the best empire at that time.
Uh um And there were Greeks who lived in
um
Anatolia, or what they call Asia Minor
back then. And the thing about the
Persian Empire is if you were a subject
city, you could do whatever you want,
but you had to pay taxes.
And these people did not like to pay
taxes. So, they revolted.
And in their revolt, they went to Sparta
and to Athens and sought help.
Okay? They basically said, "Look, we're
all Greeks.
Uh we're being oppressed by the
Persians. Could you please help us?"
What did the Spartans say?
What was the Spartan response?
No, because we don't care, okay? Your
problem, not my problem. What And what
did the Athenians say?
Yeah, sure. Let's achieve eudaimonia,
man. Let's be Achilles. Let's go over
and help them and maybe make a lot of
money for ourselves, okay?
So,
because the Persian Empire are so
powerful,
they destroyed the rebellion, okay?
And in 490
BCE,
uh
the Persians decided to attack Greece to
teach the Athenians a lesson. And this
was called the Battle of Marathon.
And in the Battle of Marathon, um we
actually don't know that much about it,
okay? The sourcing is very limited, but
what they say, okay, is in the Battle of
Marathon, there about 10,000 Athenians
versus 25,000 Persians.
That's a huge advantage for the
Persians, right?
Well,
the Athenians destroyed the Persians,
okay? The Athenians lost about 192 men.
The Persians lost about 5,000. It was a
slaughter.
And a lot of the reason why is in
military tactics.
So, the Persian Empire is huge,
okay? Lots of flat land. And in this
geography, the your main advantage is
cavalry, right?
Horse archers. That's what the Persians
were known for. Men on horses who would
run around and shoot arrows at you,
okay?
The geography of Greece was different.
It was hilly. So, you didn't really use
cavalry. It was more mainly infantry
fighting against each other. And what
the Greeks did over 100 hundred years
was develop a new military tactic called
hoplites.
Hoplites. So, hoplite that comes from
the word hoplon. Hoplon is Greek for
shield. So, these are men with large
shields and spears, okay?
The way they fought was using the
phalanx formation, phalanx.
And the innovation of phalanx
um innovation was it was basically a
wall, okay? So, men would stand together
and behind each other so that they made
a wall.
And because they had these shields and
spears, it was a moving wall,
okay? And the Persians didn't have
armor.
So, when men with armor went to battle
with when with men without armor,
usually armor wins, okay?
So, the Greeks, the Athenians, destroyed
the Persians at the Battle of Marathon.
That made the Persians even more angry,
okay?
So, in about 480
BCE,
Persia organized a massive invasion
force against
Greece.
And this massive inv- invasion force
again, um
the numbers, the data,
we can't confirm it, but we think it's
it's about half a million people. Half a
million soldiers. That's huge, okay? But
not only that, you had a huge navy.
And basically,
um
Persia called on every nation of its
empire to fight against Greece, which
included Egypt,
okay? Which included the Phoenicians,
which also included Greeks who lived in
the territory
of Persia, okay? And these Greeks are
called the Ionian
uh Greeks, okay?
So, it was a massive invasion force.
And Sparta and Athens
became allies to resist the Persian
invasion.
But there were also some Greek poleis
that sided with
uh the Persians including uh Thebes,
okay?
The Macedonians to the north was also
siding with the Persians. So, the
invasion came north from Macedonia down
here. And um you may have heard of the
Battle of Thermopylae, okay?
Thermopylae.
Um this was made famous by a movie
called 300. I'm not sure if you've seen
the movie 300, okay? But basically, it
was about 300 Spartans
uh about 5,000 other Greeks who tried to
make a stand against the Persian
invasion, and they got destroyed.
Okay? They got So, the Spartan So, so
the the Persians came in
and
the Greeks decided, "Okay, you know
what?
Uh their numbers are so much bigger than
ours. Let's retreat, okay? Back to
Sparta." And here
at Corinth, they decided to build a wall
to stop
the uh Persian advance. The problem
though is Athens is here, okay? So, the
Persians came in and burned down Athens.
Now,
what's important to understand is
the Greeks have the the concept of
polis. It's not a place. It's a
community, okay? A polis is wherever the
Greeks choose to be.
So, what happened that's very
interesting is even though the Athens
came to destroyed uh sorry, even though
Persia came to destroy Athens, the
Athenians just got into their ships,
okay? They just boarded their ships
because Athens is a naval power, and
they just
uh sailed away, okay? Do you understand?
So, Athens was uh destroyed. The city of
Athens was destroyed, but not the
community, the polis of Athens.
And so,
um but now the Greeks are in a lot of
trouble, okay? Because the what the
Persians can now do is
um basically
take their ships and sail around and
attack Sparta from behind. And this is a
huge problem for Sparta
because why? What is Sparta's ultimate
weakness?
Why is it so easy easy to defeat Sparta
in a war? What's the problem?
Do
Do you guys remember?
What are the What are the Spartans
really afraid of?
The helots, right?
Okay? The helots.
Remember? There's 10 helots for every
one Spartan. And the helots hate the
Spartans because the Spartans are
terrorizing have terrorized them for
centuries.
So, all that Persia has to do now, okay?
Very easy, is take their ships,
land on Sparta, and build forts,
defenses, and the helots would run into
run to them. Then the king King Xerxes
of Persia says, "I, the benevolent king
of Persia, declare the helots be free
people now."
Now, you have a revolution, okay? The
helots now are now armed by the
Persians. And then guess what? The
Persians are going to the helots are are
going to go kill the Spartans. Game
over, okay? Do you understand? The war
is over. That's all the Persians have to
do.
Take their ships,
sail around to the coast of Sparta,
build forts and defenses so that the
helots can run to them, give the helots
weapons,
and then let the helots run loose
against the Spartans, and the war is
over. Greece is forever destroyed, okay?
Do you understand?
Very simple, right?
The Persians did not do that, okay?
The Persian king King Xerxes had a war
council.
And there were a lot of generals his
generals who who said to King Xerxes,
"King, we've won the war, okay? We're
over Greece. We have half a million men
in Greece. There's nothing the Greeks
can do about this, okay?"
So, the Persians were feeling very
confident.
And the Greeks uh the Greek navy was
on an island called Salamis, okay?
Salamis. And they everyone was freaking
out, okay? And what the Spartans wanted
to do was say, "Let's take our navy and
defend the coastline of Sparta
because we know the Persians are going
to invade Sparta at some point. They're
going to land their ships on Sparta.
Let's take our navy
and defend
uh Sparta."
There was one Athenian general, okay?
His name is Themistocles.
Themis- Themistocles.
And he said, "You know what? That's
great for you guys, okay? But remember,
our city Athens has been destroyed. We
need to take on the Persians head-on. We
can't wait."
And the Spartans are like,
"Yeah, that's fine, but they outnumber
us three to one. They have three more
ships They have three ships for every
one ship we have. There's no way we can
beat them in a naval battle."
And Themis- Themistocles says,
"We either fight the Persians now and
achieve eudaimonia, or we Athens will be
like, 'Screw you, Spartans. We're going
to go take our ships and sail off
west to Sicily or
Africa. Who cares, okay? But we're we're
going to go away, and we're going to
leave the Persians to kill you guys.'
Okay? So, the Spartans didn't really
have a choice but to listen to the
Athenians and fight.
Then what Themistocles did was he sent a
spy to King Xerxes.
And King Xerxes was having this war
council about what to do. And most of
his generals were like,
"My great king, we've won the war.
Let's just take our ships
and attack Sparta, and the war is over,
okay?"
Then the spy sent by Themistocles says
to King Xerxes,
"Oh, great king, the entire Greek navy
is stuck in Salamis. But they're But
they want they they want to run away.
Now's your chance to attack them and
destroy the Greek navy once and for
all."
Okay?
And at this point, King Xerxes
made the decision to send his entire
navy, okay? To destroy the Greek navy at
Salamis.
And his generals were like, "Don't do
that, man. That's a risk you don't have
to take. Why do that? Why take the
Greeks on? Why fight Why fight the fight
the Greeks
um head-on when we can just starve them
out? And King King Xerxes said, "No, I I
came
to defeat the Greeks, okay? I'm the
great king. I want to defeat them at
Salamis
and build a monument to celebrate my
great victory over the Greeks.
My father, King Darius, sent an army in
490 BCE and the Athenians killed or
destroyed his army at Marathon. I'm
going to prove I'm a greater king than
my father by defeating the Greeks at
Salamis, okay? I don't want this
war of attrition, the slow war. I want
one great battle so that history will
remember me forever, okay?
So, he sends his entire force, about a
thousand ships,
to Salamis.
And Salamis is it's a strait, okay? It's
very narrow.
So, the ships have to line up and attack
the Greeks one by one, okay?
And at Salamis,
in a headlong battle, okay? The Greek
ships were heavier and the Greek ships
were manned by hoplites with armor.
And in this Battle of Salamis, the
Greeks destroyed
the Persian navy.
Okay? Do you understand?
The Persian army had won the war.
And at Salamis, they lost the war.
Okay?
Now, the problem here is whe- now that
the Persian navy has been destroyed,
supply lines
are in trouble, okay? Do you understand?
Because Greek is Greece is very poor.
Greece is a very poor nation. You cannot
resupply yourself in Greece.
How do you feed a what half half million
people? Well, you need to bring in
supplies from Persia.
But now your navy has been destroyed.
So, now King Xerxes freaks out and he
goes home. He's like, "You know what? I
burned down Athens. That's good enough
for me, okay?" And he leaves his cousin,
General Mardonius, to fight the um
Greeks, okay?
And at this point, Mardonius could have
chosen to not fight the Greeks.
Right? Because Athens has been destroyed
and Sparta is still under threat. So,
all Mardonius had to do was he was in
Thebes, okay? He was in Thebes.
All he had to do was stay in Thebes and
wait out the war, okay? This is what I
call a war of attrition, where you wait
out the other enemy because the other
enemy
has basically less resources than you,
okay? Does that make sense?
Again,
really easy for the Persians to win,
but
um Mardonius chose to fight the Greeks
at the Battle of Plataea.
And here,
it was about equal forces, 100,000
Greeks versus 100,000 Persians, and the
Greeks destroyed the Persians.
The Persians lost five times more men
than the
uh Greeks, okay?
And King uh uh General Mardonius was
killed in this battle.
So, this war that the Persians should
have won very easily, the Persians
uh lost and were completely destroyed.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay, any questions so far about
the Persian invasion?
Okay.
And because of this war,
Greece now became extremely wealthy. The
reason why is Persia is forced to
retreat
from Asia Minor and the Greeks were able
to capture a lot of treasure, okay?
Now,
um after this, Persia switches
strategies, okay? Persia never again
invades Greece because they think this
is stupid to invade Greece.
Okay? But the
Greeks don't know this. The Greeks
think, "Okay, the Persians will come
back at any point, okay?" So, the
Athenians say,
"Let's take the battle to Persia."
And what do the Spartans say?
The Spartans say, "No, we're going to go
home and that's it, okay?"
So, to to battle against the Persians,
the Athenians create something called
the Delian League.
The Delian League
is a defensive alliance
between Athens and these colonies and
islands in the Aegean.
And the idea is if the Persians come
back, we will master forces and fight
the Persians at sea.
The problem is that only Athens had a
navy. Everyone else didn't really have a
navy. So, everyone everyone else is
like, "We don't have a navy,
but we'll contribute money, okay?"
And they agreed that this money, this
treasury, would be could be only be used
against Persia
if Persia invades. Okay? So, they put
all this money on a place called Delos,
okay?
An island called Delos, and that's why
it's called the Delian League.
Right? Does that make sense? So,
basically, Athens would put up a navy
and everyone else would put up money.
And this money um
this treasury of the Delian League can
only be used in a war against Persia.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay. So, while this is happening,
Athens is the rising power
in this world.
And in 461
BCE,
a new political leader called Pericles
comes into power.
And as you should know from your
research, Pericles
is considered
um the father of Athenian democracy.
He's the one who spreads democracy
throughout Athens.
And
historians today worship
um Pericles, okay? Pericles is
considered one of the greatest leaders
ever in Western in Western history.
Okay?
Um
I'll talk more about Pericles and
democracy in future classes, okay? But I
want to show you
that Pericles was first and foremost a
politician
who was concerned about amassing and
keeping power. Does that make sense?
So, he did a lot of wonderful things for
uh Athens, but I want to show you these
things that he did, even though they
seem great, they really were about him
amassing power for himself.
Okay?
So, um the first thing he did was he
spread democracy to everyone, okay? He
basically gave every citizen the right
to vote.
And you're like, "Okay, that's great.
Direct democracy. Athens creates
democracy.
This is great, right?"
But the reason why he did that was to
change the balance of power in Athens.
So, he basically represented the lower
nobility versus the upper nobility,
right?
Usually, the upper nobility has more
power because it has more money.
Okay? It has more prestige.
So, the way for the lower nobility to
defeat the
the upper nobility is by aligning itself
with the people, okay?
Does that make sense?
And you do that by giving people the
right to vote.
And so, by doing this, Pericles
basically made himself king of Athens.
Does that make sense? In fact, he stayed
in power from 461
to 429.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right?
And to please the people even more, he
basically made corruption official.
What he did that was very important was
he basically took the money from Delos
and brought it to Athens. Basically,
Pericles said to the Delian League, "You
know what? This money in Delos, it's a
lot of money. I'm afraid that the
Persians will come and steal it, so
let's take it to Athens, okay?"
When he brought it to Athens, the next
thing he did was he spent all of it,
okay?
He built a lot of really impressive
buildings, including something called
the Parthenon.
Um
the Parthenon is this great temple to
Athena, which is a patron goddess of
Athens. They made uh the Athenian statue
out of gold, okay? They spent billions
and billions of dollars on this temple.
The reason why is when you do that,
right? You give people jobs.
And you give
uh people who support you money, okay?
So, this is basically official
corruption.
Now, there are people in the upper
nobility
who thought what Pericles was doing was
terrible for Athens. And basically, uh
in meetings, they wanted to ostracize
Pericles, right? They wanted to they
they accused Pericles of corruption, of
basically bribing the city of Athens,
and they said, "You are corrupting our
morals."
Okay? You are hurting our democracy.
Therefore, we want to ostracize you.
And there was this vote against
Pericles. And what happens? Do you guys
know?
The people voted to exile
Pericles' opponents.
Okay? Those who criticized Pericles were
now exiled from Athens. Therefore,
Pericles no longer has any political
opponents. And Pericles can do whatever
he wants.
And so, the two big innovations of
Pericles is democracy, okay?
Right?
Let's give people the right to vote and
let's give people more money, okay?
But also empire.
The reason why is
after Pericles especially stole the
money from the Delian League,
the allies were obviously angry, right?
You stole our money.
So we are out of this league. And
Pericles said, "Well, if you leave our
league, we're going to come and invade
you."
So Athens started this ex- expansionist
campaign in order to maintain its
empire. So the Delian League basically
became the Athenian Empire.
And now uh Athens got basically 20% of
its revenue
from
its allies, okay?
Does that make sense?
So that's what that's what Pericles was
doing. He was promoting democracy in
order to make sure people voted for him.
He was promoting promoting empire in
order to maintain the easy money flow
into Athens.
Empire is important because remember,
um Athens has a culture of eudaimonia.
So
empire makes the rich extremely wealthy.
You understand? Empire makes everyone
rich, but it makes the wealthy even more
so.
And so the lower nobility,
okay?
The lower nobility became very jealous.
And so the way to resolve this issue is
the lower nobility could choose to uh
invade other places, okay?
And if they win, they could make a lot
of money money for themselves. So one
place they chose to invade was um Egypt.
But that failed, okay? So throughout
this time you had a lot of Athenian
expeditions throughout the world in the
in looking to conquer new territory.
And sometimes they succeeded, but some
but a lot of times they failed as well,
okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
So
as Athens is expanding and becoming much
wealthier,
other Greek uh colonies other Greek
policies start to get angry at Athens,
okay? And Athens is basically the big
bully.
They were afraid of Persia before, but
Persia didn't really bother the Greeks.
Whereas Athens
um was a big bully. They wanted to
control
all of Greece, okay?
They basically were mafia organization
that
um
was forcing these islands in the Aegean
Sea to pay tribute to Athens. They were
trying to take more more territory from
other Greek policies.
So in 431,
the Greek policies united around Sparta
and start start start something called
the Peloponnesian War.
Okay? And historically, what most
historians will tell you is
this war was started because Sparta was
afraid
of an emerging Athens, okay? Sparta was
the hegemon. Sparta was a more was more
dominant power
uh in Greece at that time. And now that
Athens was rising, Sparta felt
threatened by Athens and therefore
declared war on Athens.
Um that's not true, okay? That's not the
reason. The reason why is because Athens
was an empire and it was going around
and bullying everyone. And so
you didn't didn't have a choice in the
matter. You got to fight Athens now or
wait for Athens to invade you, okay?
So it was because Athens was a imperial
power.
And so other nations had to other Greek
policies had no choice but to stand
against
um
Athens, okay? And Athens was an imperial
power because of its theory of
eudaimonia. Okay?
So the great irony
here, and you will see this pattern um
repeat itself throughout history, is
the thing, the culture that allows a
nation to rise, okay? And this is
eudaimonia. Will also cause it to
decline.
Does that make sense? Okay? Because it's
because of the Peloponnesian War, which
lasts from about 431
B.C. to 404 B.C.E., 27 years,
that Athens loses it its empire, okay?
So the culture, eudaimonia, that causes
Athens to rise will ultimately lead to
its decline as well.
All right?
The So
are you guys clear so far?
Please let me know if this is clear to
you, if you have any questions before
before before I continue.
Okay. So
even though Sparta and Athens are now at
war with each other,
um this war again should have been
pretty easily won by Athens. Why? What
can Athens do to destroy do to destroy
Sparta?
Do you guys know?
What can Athens do really easy
to destroy Sparta?
Helots, right?
The Athenians have ships. They can
choose to do what the Persians should
have done, but they didn't they didn't
do. Which is to basically take its navy,
land its navy on the coast, and support
the Helots in a rebellion, okay? If that
would have happened, Sparta would would
have been destroyed very quickly.
The Athenians didn't do that.
All right? Do you understand? The
Athenians didn't do that.
Now, Sparta, to counter this threat
against Athens, what should it have
done?
To counter this threat again um from um
Athens?
Exactly, thank you, okay? Its only
option in this scenario is to free the
Helots. And say to the Helots, "If you
fight for us
against Athenians,
we will give you your liberty, okay?"
And the Helots would have been "Yeah,
let's go fight for the for for for the
Spartans, okay?" So Sparta would have
increased its army 10 times. And they
could have destroyed
Athens. Sparta didn't do this either,
okay?
Do you understand?
So from a military strategy perspective,
the way the Peloponnesian War didn't
make any sense.
The only way to understand
what happened is to understand that the
very basis of conflict in society is
between the upper nobility and the lower
nobility, okay?
Do you understand?
The upper nobility is only interested in
maintaining the status quo. They're very
conservative. They don't like wars
because you can lose wars and also
because if you win wars, you have people
who are now richer than you are, okay?
Do you understand? So the upper nobility
is very conservative in both Athens and
Sparta.
Lower nobility
can only become upper nobility through
war or revolution, okay? So they're
always looking to upset the status quo.
So even though this war is going on,
internally, there's still conflict
between the upper nobility and the lower
nobility, okay? And that's why if you
look at the Peloponnesian War, a lot of
military strategy doesn't make any
sense.
Because Sparta isn't really trying to
win a war against Athens. Sparta is
trying to maintain the status quo in
Sparta, okay? Athens is not really
trying to win a war against Sparta.
Athens is trying to maintain the status
quo within Athens.
All right? An example is
Pericles, the war starts in 431 B.C.E.
And a lot of people are saying to
Pericles, "Hey, let's go invade Sparta."
And what Pericles says instead is, "Oh,
no, no, no. The Spartans are the
greatest warriors in the world. We have
no chance against Sparta. So what we'll
do is
we have these walls,
okay? We have these walls.
We'll we'll hide behind our walls
and let our navy protect us in the sea,
okay?" That was the defensive strategy
of Pericles.
And so what the Spartans could do was
they could come to Attica
and
destroy all the farmland. And the
Athenians could only watch as the
Spartans destroy the farmland. This was
this was a disaster
for the Athenians because if you think
about it, over time the Spartans could
starve out the Athenians, right?
The other problem is
if you have too many people in one
place, what happens?
You have too many people living in in in
a city, what happens usually?
Disease, right?
Disease.
So because of the overpopulation
in Athens, they had the plague,
which killed
1/3
of the Athenian population. Okay? Do you
understand? 1/3 of the Athenian
population.
If the Athenians went to war against
Sparta,
um and they lost, they would have at lo-
at at most lost about 10% of the of
their population, okay?
But because they chose not to fight and
hide behind the walls, not only did they
lose their farmland, but they lo- lost a
third of their population,
including Pericles, who died because of
the plague.
Pericles died as well as his two sons,
okay?
Does that make sense?
All right? So again, the strategy makes
no sense if you think of it from a
military perspective. It only makes
sense if you understand
there's a internal conflict in Athens
between the upper nobility and the low-
lower nobility, okay?
Pericles represents the upper nobility.
He wants to maintain the status quo.
There's a war going on, but he doesn't
really want to fight this war, okay?
He just he just wants to wait it out
because he does not want to change the
status quo.
Does that make sense?
So,
after um Pericles dies, the lower
nobility
become ascendant, okay? And because of
this war,
they propose an aggressive strategy
against the Spartans.
Okay? Basically, it's like, let's go
attack um
the Spartans
and
cause a revolution in Sparta, okay? And
this was the um
the this was proposed by Cleon,
who after um Pericles died, became uh
basically the de facto leader of Athens.
And he was considered a demagogue, okay?
If you look at the history,
um everyone says bad things about this
guy, okay? But really, what he is, he's
lower nobility who's trying to achieve
eudaimonia, okay? And he's basically
like Themistocles.
Okay?
All right? And he's a great military
strategist as well.
So, Cleon proposes this aggressive
strategy against
Sparta, and guess what happens?
Athens is now destroying Sparta.
Okay? Now, Sparta is under a lot of
pressure. It's losing the war.
So, now what Sparta Sparta um
what Sparta does is it picks a new
general, Brasidas,
and says to Brasidas,
"Listen, we're losing the war. What can
we do?"
So, Brasidas
um goes north,
and he starts to win these victories
against Athens. And his policy is this,
"Listen, um
we need to change our social structure
in order to win against Athens. So, I
So, what he does is he tell the helots,
'If you fight for me, I'm going to give
you your freedom.' And so,
a so a lot helots fight for Brasidas,
and Brasidas wins a lot of wars.
And this is And And how And how do the
Spartans feel about this?
Brasidas, who's a Spartan, is now
winning wars against Athens. And so, how
do the Spartans feel about this?
Are they happy about this?
No, they're really unhappy about this,
okay? Because it's changing their social
structure.
Do you understand?
They don't want this crap. They want the
helots to be slaves. They don't want the
helots to be free citizens who helps
them win wars, okay?
So,
what ultimately happens is, even though
Cleon and Brasidas have both proposed
strategies that allow Athens and Sparta
to win the war, ultimately, what happens
is
Cleon and Brasidas get into a battle
with each other, and they both die in
this battle. That's extremely
convenient, guys, okay? That's really,
really convenient. So, I'd be very
surprised if they actually did both die
in battle. My guess is what happened is
they were both ass- assassinated during
the battle against each other. Does that
make sense? Because ultimately,
um
both were the bigger threats to the
social structure of Sparta and Athens
than losing the war itself. Does that
make sense, guys?
Okay?
Any questions so far?
Okay.
Does that make sense?
Okay. Okay, so um
Now,
so this war keeps on going,
and then what happens is the Persia gets
involved
and gives Sparta a navy. Basically,
Persia gives Sparta a blank check.
And because Sparta is so conservative
and insular, it doesn't really know how
to um have a navy, okay? It doesn't know
how to fight with a navy.
In fact, Sparta is militarily like in
terms of strategy, it's actually very
weak, okay? If If it's like Spartan
soldiers by themselves are very strong,
but in terms of like overall military
strategy, Sparta, because it's so
conservative and insular, it's very weak
against it's very weak compared with
Athens. But Persia has a lot of money,
and Persia is bankrolling Sparta, okay?
And eventually, Persia says to Sparta,
"Hey guys,
why don't you try a new strategy? This
strategy is this,
if a general is winning against
Athenians, promote the guy, okay?"
And you're like, "Okay, well, that makes
total sense." The Spartans didn't do
that, okay? The Spartans were not
concerned about winning the war, they
were concerned about maintaining their
social order. Do you understand? There's
a social hierarchy in Sparta, that's
what's important, not winning the war.
And then there was this a Spartan
commander, Lysander,
and he was really the only Spartan
who knew how to win naval battles.
The problem with Lysander was he was a
half citizen,
which meant that his his
his father was a Spartan, but not the
mother, do you understand? Only if both
your parents are citizens are you
allowed to be a citizen. So, Lysander
was really looked up looked down upon in
Sparta, but he could win naval battles.
So, he wasn't promoted. The Persians
said to the Spartans, "Listen, this is
stupid, okay? Lysander is a great
commander, you have to promote him." The
Spartans didn't really have a choice in
the matter,
and so Lysander, after he was promoted,
single-handedly won the war against
Athens. He laid siege to Athens in 404
BCE,
and then
um Athens had no choice but to surrender
because they were out of food, okay?
Does that make sense?
Now,
for 27 for 27 years, Sparta and Athens
were at war with each other. They were
killing each other.
Now, Athens has finally been defeated.
So, what do you think should should
happen now?
What should be What should happen to
Athens now?
Okay, the answer is nothing happened to
Athens,
okay?
Usually, if you lose a war
in this world, what happens is they come
and kill all the men and enslave all the
women.
And that's what the Persians wanted,
okay? That's what That's what the other
Greek cities wanted to happen to Athens.
The Spartans didn't do anything to
Athens. They left Athens alone,
okay?
And there are many different
explanations for this. One explanation
is Sparta wanted to maintain the balance
of power in the Greek world, okay? If
they destroyed Athens, then Persia could
come back and destroy Sparta, okay?
Um
but another explanation is, well, guess
what, guys?
The upper nobility of Sparta and the
upper nobility of Athens,
they're good friends with each other,
okay? Do you understand?
Rich people tend to marry each other.
They tend to be good friends with each
other, okay? So, Athens and Sparta
weren't really enemies, do you
understand? They had to fight this war
because of the internal pressures from
the no- low low nobility. But because
this war is killing off so much low- so
much lower nobility, it maintained the
status quo. Does that make sense?
All right?
Do you guys understand so far? Any
questions?
All right. So, I'm going to conclude
with evidence for this theory.
Okay?
So, uh what what what I just said, like
the war is really about um killing off
internal dissent, not really about
beating the other enemy. That's very
controversial, okay?
So, I will give you some evidence for
this theory, and it's called rat utopia.
So, in the in the 19 um '60s and '70s,
there was an American researcher,
American scientist, his name is James B.
Calhoun, okay?
And he was interested in the question,
"What would it be
like for humans to live in a world of
abundance?
What would it mean for humans to live in
a world where everything was perfect,
where you didn't have to fight for food,
where food was just given to you, okay?
A utopia.
What would it What What would it be
like? Well, he couldn't really
experiment on
humans, so he decided to experiment on
rats instead, okay? So, he built this
universe, okay? Basically, this big
house,
and food was plentiful for rats.
The food, the water was plentiful for
rats. So, rats could just play all day,
okay?
Now, I'm not sure if you know about
anything about rats, but the thing about
animals,
and this is a very important idea, is
that animals live in a
heavily
ritualized
and rules-
based world.
Does that make sense, guys?
We think of animals as chaotic. No, no,
no. If you actually study their
societies, ants, monkeys, rats, they
live in an extremely rule-based,
heavily ritualized world, okay? So, let
me let let me give you an example of
this.
So, uh rats, when they mate with each
other, what happens is this.
Um
a female rat is interested in having
sex, okay? So, she's going out, and then
and then a male rat spots this. He sees
the female rat
in heat. So, what he does is he gets on
a he gets on a mound, okay? Where she
can see him, and he starts to dance.
Okay? He starts to dance.
And the female rat becomes interested,
and
he sees she's interested, so he comes
down and they start chasing each other,
okay?
They're having fun together. And then
And then what she does is she runs home
and hides her hides herself in her
burrow.
The male rat just stands outside and
waits for her to come out.
After some time, she comes out and they
run again run together again, and then
she runs back again.
They do this many, many times until
finally she lets him catch him, and then
they have sex.
Okay? And then And then after they have
sex, they have children, and they start
a family together, okay? Does that make
sense?
Okay? That's how rats usually behave.
When they they often like to play with
each other, and they fight, but it's
very playful, okay? So, there's lots of
rules, there's lots of rituals in this
rat society.
But that's out in nature.
In the world of James B. Calhoun, he
creates rat utopia, okay?
Where everyone has enough to eat.
And at some point, the society breaks
down.
Okay?
These These rituals, these rules all
break down. What happens is
male rats, when they start fighting each
other,
they become very violent.
They no They no longer play. They're
actually trying to kill each other, and
some actually die.
Okay? And this like mating ritual, it
breaks down.
So, the male rats don't even try to
dance, okay? They're not dancing. They
just see a a female and they rape her.
Okay? And it's like gang rape.
It's not one male, it's like lots of
males raping her.
These gangs of rats, they try to break
into burrows, homes, and try to rape
the wife,
okay? The mother.
And at first, the husband is fighting
off these other rats, right? But
eventually what happens is he gets
tired,
and he just runs away, okay? He just
abandons the family.
Now, the female rat is responsible for
fighting off now the other rats.
But she becomes so traumatized, she
starts to beat everyone up, including
her own children. So, she kicks her
children out of the house.
It is a complete social breakdown. And
after a few more months of this crap,
the entire colony of rats dies. The
entire society collapses. Does that make
sense?
All right?
This So, this is what we call rat
utopia. It's been done many times, and
each time they do this, this happens. At
some point,
the society will collapse.
Okay? And this makes no sense to us.
Everyone has enough food to eat,
everyone should be happy, okay? Why does
Why does society collapse?
Okay. So, there are different
explanations for this.
Um James B. Calhoun, his argument is if
there's too much food, there's
overpopulation. There's overpopulation,
then that creates conflict. And then the
conflict causes the rules to collapse.
Okay?
The problem though with this theory is
the colony never became overpopulated,
okay?
There was space for everyone, but at
some point,
everyone started to fight each other.
All right?
So, this is my theory, and this and this
goes back to the Peloponnesian War.
It has to with
the idea of status.
So, if in a world of abundance, in a
world of wealth, who benefits the most?
It's the elderly, old people, okay?
Old people can live a lot longer in a
society that is wealthy and abundant and
and abundant, okay? Does that make
sense?
Okay?
But then what happens is
the status
becomes locked in, which prevents
younger rats, younger people, from
ascending into power and status. Does
that make sense?
Okay?
So, the idea is
the metaphor is these rats are online,
okay? I'm I'm waiting for to climb the
mountain, okay? This is the mountain
top.
You're waiting and waiting to climb the
mountain.
And everyone's moving along, it's slow,
but you're still moving along, okay? And
eventually you will
reach the mountain top, which is where
you want to be.
But let's just say for whatever reason,
the line stops moving, okay? Everyone's
stuck in place.
Well, then you get very anxious. You get
very stressed out. You get very
agitated.
You're like, when is it my turn?
And it's never going to come because the
people at the top won't leave.
Okay? So, what do you do? Well, you
start kicking the people
behind you, right?
You start fighting with with with with
with each other. You understand?
That's this is what we call rat utopia.
In a world of abundance, in a world of
extreme wealth,
old people do not die.
If they do not die, it is impossible for
young people to ascend into power and
status.
And so, they have all these energies,
and
because they cannot
reach their potential, they become
violent and start attacking each other.
Okay?
So, that's rat utopia. That's what rats
do.
But if you look at the Peloponnesian War
and what happened between Athens and
Sparta, it's really no different.
Okay?
It's really no different.
They were killing each other for no
reason. Extreme violence, which led to
nothing. Okay?
431 BCE, the political world was no
different from 404 BC. The only
difference is a lot young people died,
okay?
In wars against each other.
So, that's my argument to you.
If societies become too wealthy,
you have a problem of rat utopia.
Okay?
If you're at utopia,
societies will then engage in
wars that will lead eventually to its
collapse. And that's what happened to
Athens.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right. Any questions about this?
Does Does that make sense to you guys?
All right?
Any questions?
Yeah.
Okay. So,
um the question is
in a rat utopia, why do the mothers want
to start attacking the kids, okay?
Um
Okay. So, this is actually a complicated
question.
The answer is this. Humans are different
from rats,
okay? So, humans have the ability to
reason and to
uh adapt to new circumstances, okay?
Does that make sense? Rats don't. These
There are these rules in place, okay?
And if these rules are broken, then the
rats don't know how to adapt.
So, if you're a rat mother, you have a
husband, okay? Your understanding is
the husband will protect you from
strangers.
Okay?
Your Your understanding is if someone is
if someone is violent towards you, you
have to be violent against that person,
okay?
So, in a situation where the husband
leaves,
the husband runs away or or is dead, the
mother does not understand this new
order anymore.
So, the mother becomes The word we use
is traumatized.
If you're traumatized, you can no longer
reason, okay?
You're so focused on protecting
yourself, you attack everything and
everyone, including your own children.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, this is experiment because
obviously this would not happen in real
life, okay? There's no way the rats get
free food in real life. So, they have
this experiment where the experimenters
gave the rats free food every day, and
this is what happened.
No, no. So, the experiment is
the rats were left by themselves, okay?
The rats could do whatever they wanted.
The only thing the experimenters did was
feed them every day.
Okay? If you do that, if there's
abundance and there's wealth, there's
you then you have complete social
collapse.
Okay?
Um
Okay. Okay. All right. So, okay. All you
need to understand is this, okay?
The entire society collapses,
okay? How it collapses can be different
from family to family, but the entire
society collapses. Everyone dies at the
end, okay?
Do you Do you Do you understand?
Okay. Okay. Any more questions?
Any more questions?
So, I I know this is a lot to take in,
okay?
This is very confusing, and this is very
hard. Uh but it's okay. Just ask any
questions or
points where you want me to clarify.
Okay. So, next class we will do Greek
theater. And then after that, we'll do
Greek philosophy, which includes Plato,
um
Socrates, and Aristotle, okay?